all right the this next clip i admit to
you
110
is disaster porn
mike lindell the ceo of mike pillow
the ceo of mypillow who i sometimes
refer to as mike pillow
he is back on the steve bannon show on
real america's voice war room you know
it's a very long name
and he has a new
blockbuster lawsuit with evidence to get
donald trump reinstated
um
bannon asks him when is it going to
court
and pillow says it's going to court in
two weeks we're gonna do since it's the
end of the year
we're gonna take a tour through 2021
with pillow
all of the different times that he said
he has all of these blockbuster lawsuits
and things so this is the new one he has
another deadline and it's coming up very
soon is in any it's like throwing a gun
in a river where you killed someone you
can't throw away the evidence so that's
what they've tried to do but
hey let's say
let's go
let's go to commercial break just when's
the f when's this finally going to take
place
uh it should be by within the next two
weeks um we've got it all ready to go
we've just got to go get it filed in dc
with uh with the judge
because in
okay that's that's the new one in in
just a couple weeks it's gonna happen
now remember all of the times he said
this i don't have two hours to play all
of the instances but let's go through a
couple of these remember back on may
25th pillow appeared with steve bannon
and he said he's gathering evidence and
he's got white hat hackers
and any any moment attorneys general
were going to be on board and before you
knew it trump was going to be back but
your air game walk us through the
critical path of the air game critical
well it started you know when i first
got the evidence and that that was on
january 9th and as i got more and more
and did my own due diligence and had
teams of people gathering this what we
have is we have cyber they're called
cyber packets these are forensic packets
that you can't change they're 100
evidence of each flip that happened each
attack by china these are cyber these
are immutable
cyber packets and presumably not packets
of mustard and ketchup
and and what i did then is i wanted to
make sure
i went out and got the the best white
hat hackers uh different ones from
different uh parts of the government
that are that are protect our country
they validated everything so now we have
our royal flush to bring to the supreme
court but what we're doing now we have
about i believe it's five different
cyber teams different teams where we're
doing awesome so he had elements of
cyber and they were ready to go that was
may 25th
um that of course didn't happen
then
he had the august 13th deadline august
13th deadline he missed that one and he
said well don't worry i have a new
deadline 2022 2024
people want change now we can't wait to
2024 for things to reverse this country
is going down a road right now that has
to be reversed now yeah it has to happen
now it's trump 2021 100
trump 2021
and it's uh this election when it does
get pulled down you know there are so
many other down tickets affected maybe
the supreme court that they just do a
whole new election which is fine but
remember everybody we have to melt down
the machines and make prison bars out of
them exactly melt the machines down now
he said it would definitely happen in
2021 it is of course december 30th 2021.
we are down to the last uh about 30
you know 30 something hours left in the
year
uh didn't happen then we go to october
22nd where mike pillow said he was
canvassing for voter fraud in 20 states
which is of course weird because he
claimed in may to have all the evidence
why are you now canvassing a year after
the election but that's what he was
doing supposedly tell us about your
efforts
are we making pride in your mind are we
making progress you're not a guy fools
yourself right well only in his mind is
progress being made that's actually an
interesting way to phrase it you built
this company out of nothing to be one of
the most important manufacturing
companies
are you wasting your time or do you
believe you're getting traction as
you're going around because i i try to
we try to talk every day and i know
you're all over the country yeah you're
right pres presenting with attorney
general's representing with the
secretary of state
the audience because look the audience
loves you but are you wasting your time
are you getting traction on this
no we're getting traction i've uh i've i
met with five states in three days
that's why i couldn't come on their show
this week it's been i've been very busy
i fly on one state to another i haven't
been named in the states i've told the
attorney general's this stuff it's all
in confidence till we all sign this
together and guys please bannon and
pillow both attorney generals it's
attorneys general they're attorneys
they're not generals please and put this
out the second or two the tuesday before
thanksgiving before the supreme court so
that was that new deadline tuesday
before thanksgiving tuesday before
thanksgiving and then a little more time
went by and again again um this was just
like f a week later
again uh bannon says it's gene right
before thanksgiving it's absolute genius
of course it didn't happen what i love
about this they said hey if you just get
trump out orange man bad you get biting
you can stop you can start having
holidays again right without arguing at
the table and at each other's throats
but mike lindell comes in and he's going
to go to wednesday the eve of
thanksgiving on a marathon so you can go
back and have fistfights
the family squabbles lindell you're a
genius
like you could have thought of this
the country's gonna go back at your
holidays are ruined again okay no no no
no no it's different now 30 some percent
of democrats now believe this country
was stole and through the machines this
is going to be do you guys think bannon
really believes this stuff or is he just
entertaining it for the clicks in any
case mike pillow's guarantee of a 2021
reinstatement of donald trump is down to
its last 30-something hours it's not
going to happen it's not going to happen
but there will be a new deadline i am
sure and if you're listening today and
you want to see some of these clips
we'll have them on our instagram you can
find us on instagram at david pakman
show and we will take a quick break and
be back right after this